monsieur koic merci madame la Présidente
le présent amendement propose de de
plafonner à 30 fois les écarts de
rémunération entre les salaires au sein
d'une entreprise pour rappel à la fin du
19e siècle le banquier John Pierrepont
Morgan connu sous le nom de JP Morgan
estimer qu'un dirigeant d'entreprise ne
devait jamais percevoir plus de 20 fois
la rémunération moyenne de ses salariés
que dirait-il aujourd'hui du du du
salaire du PDG de la banque qui porte
encore son nom et qui avoisine les 30
millions de dollars par an que dirait
Henry Ford figure du capitalisme
industriel qui préconiser un écart
maximal de rémunération de 1 à 40 des
écarts de revenus lorsque ceux des
directeurs généraux des 500 plus grosses
entreprises américaines allai de 1 à
373 vous le savez depuis des années nous
observons des rapports de plus en plus
haut entre haut et bas salaire rien
qu'entre 2009 et 2014 la rémunération
des dirigeants du CAC 40 ACC cru de 45 %
soit plus de deux fois plus vite que la
moyenne des salaires de leur entreprise
est quatre fois plus vite que le salaire
minimum dans un contexte inflationnisme
fort minant le budget des Français est
devenu insupportable alors que les
marges ont chuté de 25 % pendant la
pandémie et que de nombreux travailleurs
ont connu le chômage partiel la baisse
de la rémunération des grands patrons a
été limitée à 11 %. et encore cette
baisse n'était pas durable si le salaire
du PDG total énergie s'élevit à 6,15
million d'euros en 2019 il était encore
de 6 million d'euros en 2021 c'est 376
fois le SMIC le mauvais partage de la
valeur au sein des entreprises alimentee
les inégalités dans notre pays et M
durablement notre contrat social de plus
les écarts de salaires croiss nuis au
climat de l'entreprise selon un sondage
ifob publié en janvier 2011 3 Français
sur 4 sont favorables au plafonnement
des salaires dans ce contexte cet
amendement propose de plafonner la
rémunération à 30 fois la rémunération
moyenne du décile de salaire le plus bas
afin de lutter contre les inégalités
promouvoir la cohésion au sein des
entreprises et maintenir le pouvoir
d'achat de nos
concitoyens